[Music]
so in Asia there is a an obsession with
and with light skin like beam light skin
yes this with not wanting to be darker
and wanting to look fairer and
complexion which Asia though I think oh
I think I think all of Asia yeah and
like to my knowledge to even like I
don't know if Mexico has the products
that is hardcore hardcore but like there
is like still like this like pedestal
that people put on like like people that
have fair skin is Mexican
yes manage Mexican Veda like the darker
yes so in Asia I think this is a Thai
Thai company they came out with a
whitening cream called milk lotioning
milk lotion whitening skin that's the
name of this thing and this is the
results you see Mike's eyes that's dead
just call it dead cream that's what
everyone's calling it there are like
this is not whitening this is dead any
this is a cream it looks like morbus
dusting doesn't look like that bratwurst
the white one the white bratwurst
sausage just like coated like the white
um yes yeah I know it's so Valley you
see the veins and stuff
[ __ ] that I thought there's a whole like
emo white girl community that would love
this or like a vampire goth community or
like things like Thai Goths right now
are like finally got bang long dead
cream go on does it actually make you
gay I'm only done inside well on the
outside it's like mmm
side effects include death what's up
[ __ ] so this person didn't use it that
person they got weird hands though but
that looks like a white person's hand
though like one the piece it looks like
Michael Jackson's head yeah oh look a
bit alike
let's be lighter than then white person
that's just wider than albinos like the
master on this I don't know they no
one's reporting on the permanence thing
I hope it's not you know I hope there's
no bleach in this thing that's like
bleaching the skin I don't even know
that does you want it you want a jar I
get for your bubble definitely white you
have a dead but hope we could rub that
on your balls and they're all like nice
and light I like the color in the ball
look at cue balls what oh [ __ ] Thaksin
there this is the picture of the same
guy why does he look like he just has a
movie is a [ __ ] weird movie there's
like albino but he was like also could
like lightning had something to it yeah
like smart and read all the books in the
world yeah yeah he was hot wait looks
like those [ __ ] soldiers from the
road warrior Mad Max said dude like if I
saw my son like that I'd be like Oh
Franco that's what you're gonna look
like but then for them they're like
Daniel look good now imagine all the
panties are like oh ha she looks like a
vampire but yeah so yeah so this took
over the Thai social media scene a bit
cracked about yeah they're cracking up
that they're calling it look they even
talked about it it looks like powder
protagonist Jeremy powder read which is
the character oh my god talking about
yeah and there's talking about how they
all everyone looks like vampires and
zombies and yeah that's that I mean
which brings to mind a lot of US
companies now are opting not to use the
word whitening and any other creams and
they're being very careful cream whitens
like the TV other than you yeah yeah
like like toothpaste but then like
there's a whole white nurse but that's
but what do they were they gonna cry
lightning I don't know if they have
leaching a word to go with a mic so like
you know Unilever for example has a like
a branch of there's called called Fifi
Ferran love enough
fefe because he kept saying wow get
[ __ ] in prison but yeah Unilever has a
company called fair and lovely it's like
a line of products and now they're
trying to do away with fair part and
then any of the products that use the
words whitening lightening fairness
they're trying to but those are skin
products these are skin product between
scam products and then and these
products yeah I think it's just the
terminology I think you put in your hair
to like light in it so they won't use
that anymore
I don't know I don't there's there's no
like answer in terms of I like
lightening it cuz it's like no like any
right to mean lightining no let's go
with lightening I like lightening
they're all jagged and it's electrocuted
it [ __ ] it up [ __ ] yeah dude
but yeah so because of all like the
black lives matter stuff that's
happening right now a lot of companies
are trying to like change the logos
right and then now even like the
terminology in terms of how they address
or like sell their products are now kind
of under under scrutiny it's like up the
source being used more than ever now in
reference to skin like a skin I think
you're right it's it's the skin cream
that makes sense I think when it gets
teeth it's like it's just I'm yellow on
yellow but the yellow might be bad right
for skin it makes sense because there
are different skin like races right but
then everyone's teeth want they want it
to be white and it's not only white
people that have white teeth
yeah that's like what you would think
you know racism isn't like you know
you're judging me by the color of my
teeth yeah point they do coke everyone
does well that's different
yes they did they did a study about
people with with not good teeth yes
that's not really
see through them but yeah that's ugly
ISM has no color I think I don't think
that's gonna get cured anytime soon oh I
wish it would yeah you can always fix
our teeth we can always whiten it bleach
it braces but you can't change our erase
so I think that sometimes though people
they look at what happens in Asia with
the Western perspective and think oh
they're just trying to be white but in
reality like they've been this way for
like [ __ ] hundreds of years where the
Royals would wouldn't work on classism
it's classism that's what it is for
Mexico it's like if you're dark it's
just cuz you're a field worker and you
want to be associated at least back in
the day I went out but at least back in
the day it's like oh no I'm not a I'm
not a blue colored person like I don't
do [ __ ] yeah what if there's a dark
bikini model with a triangle tan or her
titties like a higher class than the
rest of her her tan lines are higher
class just cuz you buy me the ten is
different than your actual skin color
yeah and you can tell that there is a
farmer worker at the farm worker butter
titty trying you just want to think
about girls tits it's like a little bit
of a Trojan horse to get [ __ ] but it's
weird though I don't like albino albino
like super albino cuz you're Western you
grew up out here maybe if you grow over
there Asia yeah that's true people white
like white white skin yeah they're like
whiter than white people yeah cuz we had
friends that that don't want to be in
the Sun and everywhere they go they
carry an umbrella and we're like they
want to be geisha white that's it's like
why does the white board did they want
black teeth though
well that's ancient yes oh I'm talking
about like now guess who one looks like
teeth it's crazy yeah cuz the grinding
yeah I don't know man they want to look
like a canvas or something and I think
that's okay you know like you factor
style yeah then that's cool and we
shouldn't judge that because I mean we
get a [ __ ] ton of plastic surgery out
here like what's different it's like you
also get a tan true
what's the difference what do bruises
look like if you have this white lotion
people questions we need to answer then
you get a bruise oh man
that's pretty crazy yeah it's very when
they die then and does he put the lotion
on his balls and genitals - or that
she'd art is Oh first add lines that's
the first step you're staying
what's burnin if you like the house -
right do you think it bleaches or do you
think it's a it's a cream I just hope
it's like a clarity on the planet right
now we just buy it and all of us put it
on let's [ __ ] do it like we reverse
henna I don't know why tattoos alright
yeah good constant sensible there's
gotta be some sort of hydroxide in there
it's an Asian product yeah I don't know
enough peroxide bleaches like rocks I
believe the skin yes it does
really yeah I've ever tried bleaching
like your hair yeah and then even the
parts the way it touches her scalp that
it becomes lighter temporary unless you
get a tan but if you leave it on your
skin long enough it will bleach it oh
did you know like skin you get new skin
like every three days or something like
that it's very fast
it's crazy fortnight yeah Oh skin for
your character
Oh him in terms of time yeah a fortnight
difference attorney using my really
really current terminology like no one
here plays games that's why I got it
coaster was like okay so you're yet a
skins is like for your character you
could you could change making what's the
motive for night two weeks 14 days -
yeah yeah well they call it for tie in
the game I thought it's because you
build forts yeah you know night yeah in
14 days the first version of it was not
very popular super slow I want to get
that cream and try it if it won't damage
my skin try it on your butthole first no
why Hey
you know you know why that's the deme
style yeah but I'm not gonna do it he'll
glance at this in the deme style sorry
what does that mean sir everyone the D
was the bleaches [ __ ] where would you
put it first Joe all over my bodies from
Harry you wanna dress like a little pad
well if I know that it's safe look like
that
for fun I would I think you'll be
hilarious no no yeah the Halloween
costume or you want to walk like I feel
like you've your skin's like this then
you're fearing the Sun for five minutes
you're getting burned right because
there's no melanin or anything at all
you have melon underneath it's just a
cover it's cosmetics but it's on a cover
if you could see the green of your vein
really kind of like takes away the
pigment yeah it takes away the picture
that grease from my vein here yeah
because you're seeing through you're
seeing through the skin now you really
see the veins
yeah no if that's how it works cuz if it
was a cover and find his cream I'm like
looking for it cover like your veins are
just be a bumpy white theme you wouldn't
be able to see a green of the vein yeah
like if we're putting on white paint I
thought it just makes it show like
fluorescent lights accentuate well it's
like it's pretty cause like you could
see green and like your veins here but
you could see the green in your veins
here so because it's lighter skin right
yeah and because it's closer to the
surface
let me flex you will cool I can get my
veins pop all the reason did we check
this out thought you'd never ask